here's a TV moment that should have won
some kind of award I like you a lot a
lot a lot a lot isn't that like every
woman wants to hear when she's with the
man of her dreams I've never ever ever
slow that blends oak trail I know your
husband gotcha I said that's how he got
so let's be real Juan Pablo is not the
only bad boy to give the bachelor a bad
name but now you know there's a good old
boy a country boy Chris and is he gonna
bring nice back to the show pretty much
what you see is what you get with me I
mean I am gonna be open-hearted and just
get to know these girls seriously don't
you just want to bring him home to mom
there are so many reasons to love Chris
soules first off it is adorable that the
33 year old farmer from Iowa still gets
giddy like a little kid I feel like this
is a dream somebody needs to slap me
awake meow does that matter yeah he is
all about his family I kind of look
probably more than anything compared the
women that I'm dating to my sisters and
mother and most of all he is nothing
like the last bachelor what you just
made me go through I would never want my
children having a father like you Juan
Pablo was just one of many notorious
jerks from the show you don't know me
and I wouldn't have done it and if you I
don't know you please stop interrupting
me the thing is oh yes who can forget
season 14 s mr. it's all about me Jake
Pavelka when I got down on me and I got
interrupted and the season before that
mr. can't make a decision Jason Mesnick
Jos Molly after he had already chosen
Melissa if you saw guns from all so mad
at you so yes we are happy about prints
farming bringing the nice back but he
did get some blowback for this comment
he made do Andy what would I do here
well I mean there's uh there's an
opportunity to be a homemaker there's
still risk that he's a little blah and a
little too safe but at least he's in
this for the right reasons I'm at the
point in my life where I want to find
love this is great but I admit I do
watch The Bachelor for some
cringe-worthy moments that's why
everybody watched what does that say
about us
we ask you're on our et facebook page
who's the biggest jerk in bachelor
history congrats Juan Pablo you won in a
landslide seventy-nine percent of the
vote